[Musik]
hey leute wir machen heute ein typisches
ramadan rezept nämlich dass er seinen
penis das ist türkisch und weil es ganz
einfach übersetzt ramadan fladenbrot ihr
kennt natürlich alle pegel ich meine
fidel wer kämpft nicht und das ist so
ein typisches ramadan ein bisschen
anders die form und ich zeige euch jetzt
die ganz einfache zubereitung vorher
noch ganz kurz eine kleine info dieses
ramadan fladenbrot gibt in der türkei
immer nur am hammer dann also wirklich
nur einen monat lang im jahr
in deutschland haben wir das glück da
gibt es das ganze jahr über in
ausgewählten türkischen bäckerei aber
wir machen uns heute selber und es
schmeckt unglaublich lecker und ich
zeige sich jetzt alle erstmal die
zutaten für den teig
wir benötigen mehr lauwarme milch
lauwarmes wasser öl da habe ich
sonnenwinkel verwendet außerdem frische
hefe ihr könnt ihr auch gern trockene
verwendet zucker und salz für unseren
hefeteig habe ich mir jetzt eine
schüssel genommen ich habe jetzt hier
die schüssel der küchenmaschine denn ich
werde erst mit der küchenmaschine kneten
und dann mit den händen weitermachen ihr
könnt aber auch vollständig auf die
küchenmaschine verzichten
und ich nehme jetzt hier meine milch das
ist ganz wichtig dass die lauwarm ist so
um die 32 grad genauso wie das wasser es
darf nicht heißer als 40 grad sein sonst
wird die hefe zerstört apropos hefe die
gebe ich jetzt hier rein und ich nehme
es frische hefe ihr könntet jetzt aber
auch eine tüte von der trockenhefe
verwenden
das gebe ich jetzt noch mit dazu und
damit die hilfe jetzt noch einen
nährstoff hat gebe ich zucker mit dazu
und rühre dass alles gut um
so jetzt hat sich die hier fällt dadurch
dass ja medium wasser lauwarm sind
aufgelöst und ich gebe jetzt den deckel
drüber und was das ganze so acht bis
zehn minuten lang stehen und dann geht's
weiter mit name weiter und ich habe
jetzt die gesagt die küchenmaschine
genommen gleichzeitig aber sowieso mit
den händen weiter und ich finde man hat
auch mit den händen ein besseres gefühl
später wenn man in teig kneten und jetzt
gebe ich das öl mit dazu kbc sondern
verwendet ihr könnt auch gerne olivenöl
verwenden das mache ich auch ab und zu
schlägt auch sehr lecker und jetzt nach
und nach das mehl dazugeben und langsam
kneten und dann auch das salz noch mit
rein geben nicht vergessen
[Musik]
ja
so ca drei minuten habe ich das schöne
knetet allerdings nehme ich sie jetzt
raus und drehte das noch weiter mit den
händen auf der arbeitsfläche und er
teilt ist ja noch ein bisschen klebrig
wir brauchen einen teig der nicht mehr
klebt aber auch nicht zu hart ist also
das genaue mittelding und dann wird der
perfect und jetzt nehme ich mir noch
etwas mehl zur hilfe ihr könnt auch nie
genau so sicher sein wie viel gramm mehl
gaggenau reinkommt dann müsste dann
einfach schauen manchmal brauche ich 500
gramm
manchmal 580 ist darf halt einfach nicht
zu klebrig und auch nicht zu fest sein
so der teig ist jetzt richtig schön
geschmeidig und jetzt vorm wir ihn noch
zu einer kugel und dann gebe ich ihn
zurück in die schüsse
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und wenn ihr die schüssel mit etwas mehl
auskleidet und auf den teig auch noch
mehr gibt dann kann uns später nichts
mehr ankleben
jetzt gebe ich den deckel drüber ihr
könnt auch ein küchentuch neben
hauptsache schön waren und verschlossen
und jetzt muss der teig 45 minuten lang
gehen nach der garzeit ist der hefeteig
jetzt doppelt so groß geworden und als
nächstes gegen ihn auf unser backblech
hier ist ganz wichtig legt unbedingt ein
backpapier oben drüber und streut das
ganze noch mit etwas mehl aus denn dann
bleibt wird auch nichts mehr kleben was
auch noch sehr wichtig ist einfach den
tag hier raus nehmen und hitze nicht mit
dem nudelholz darüber gehen das machen
wir hier nicht einfach raus und leben
direkt aufs backblech
[Musik]
das fladenbrot es bleibt nämlich richtig
schön fluffig wenn ihr das mit den
händen macht ihr könnt euch da ein
bisschen mehr zu hilfe nehmen und dann
ganz einfach mit den händen aus brighton
[Musik]
den tag habe ich jetzt auf ca 8 mm dicke
ausgebreitet und er ist relativ groß
also ich glaube da werden viele leute
von satt wenn man eine suppe nebenbei
serviert natürlich mehr als vier findest
es groß ich glaube wir schaffen es sogar
zu zweit so an als nächstes nehmen wir
uns eine art hilfe dass wir das muster
reinfinden das ramadan fladenbrot also
langsam gelöst hat ein ganz typisches
muster und dafür nehmen uns jetzt etwas
mehl und leitungswasser und verrühren
das erst mal
[Musik]
sondern als nächstes tut mir unsere
finger da rein ja ihr habt richtig
gehört einfach rein damit und jetzt ein
rand bilden und danach kommen diese
typischen quadrate oder rauten ganz wie
ihr möchtet
so der teig muss jetzt noch mal gehen
diesmal nur 20 minuten das ganze
natürlich zugedeckt und in 20 minuten
zeige ich euch die richtig leckere
glasow für obendrauf so die zweite
wahrte hunde ist jetzt um und ihr seht
schon also der teig ist ja noch ein
bisschen eingezeichnet aber eben nicht
mehr ganz so das heißt wir nehmen uns
jetzt eine gabel das ist immer so der
erste schritt ist immer diese mehl
wasser mischung und damit den teig so
ein bisschen eindrücken und der zweite
schritt beim rasanten ist immer mit der
gabel einfach nochmal nachfahren
[Musik]
so optimal und als nächstes kommt die
glasur von der ich gerade gesprochen
habe ich finde genauso hat sich aber so
ein bisschen an wie torten und kuchen
natürlich also ich weiß nicht wie es
nennen soll aber das macht das ganze
total besonders und zwar habe ich hier
drei zutaten 1 eigelb etwas
sonnenblumenöl hier bitte kein olivenöl
nehmen und joghurt und das ganze
verrückte jetzt und dann ergibt das eine
schöne glasow eine schöne kruste
gleichzeitig auch geschmack und hübsches
aussehen
[Musik]
so alles schöne pinselt perfekt und als
nächstes schwarzkümmel und sesam oder
und das ist immer so geschmackssache
möchte die beides möchte er ein von
beiden aber ich finde ohne schwarzgeld
ist es nicht dasselbe also unbedingt
schwarzkümmel drauf freuen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so ihr lieben wir haben es geschafft wir
dürfen in den ofen tun und das ganze bei
200 grad ober und unterhitze für ca 20
bis 25 minuten bis sie schön goldbraun
ist und dann am besten noch warmen
genießen meint er ist jetzt ganz frisch
aus dem ofen bekommen und es riecht so
gut die ganze küche riecht nach frisch
gebackenem fladenbrot und ich möchte
noch mal ganz kurz die konsistenz zeigen
also wenn man hier so rein drückt dann
gibt das so ein bisschen widerstand und
so ist es genau perfekt also das kann
jetzt ganz frisch aus dem ofen und es
gebe ich euch noch einen kleinen tipp
wenn ihr wollt doch so schön knusprig
bleibt die oberfläche zumindest ist es
ja fluffig dann ganz einfach ein
feuchtes küchentuch obendrüber leben und
etwas ausdampfen lassen 23 minuten und
dann könnte es genießen
[Musik]
und weil wir nicht genug von frisch
gebackenem packen können habe ich gleich
zwei gebacken also nicht wundern
hier ist nicht gleich noch eins und das
rezept ist aber für ein großes
fladenbrot ausgelegt wenn ihr so wie ich
die doppelte menge machen möchte dann
ganz einfach alles verdoppeln und dann
nacheinander button ihr könnt das ganze
auch ganz einfach luftdicht verpacken in
einer brotbox zum beispiel und dann
könnt ihr das am nächsten tag auch noch
genießen die genauen mengenangaben wie
schreibe ich euch wie immer hier unten
in der infobox leute ihr müsst ihr
versprechen macht es nach und schickte
fotos mit dem hashtag ekis kitchen auf
instagram und facebook darauf freue ich
mich immer so richtig und jetzt wendet
euch ganz ganz viel spaß im nachbacken
einen schönen start und bis zum nächsten
mal das gewiss kitchen
[Musik]